kate is with us in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania hi Kate how are you
hey Dave I'm doing well it's really good
to talk to you you too what's up
so I'm a question my fiance and I have
about three hundred and seventy-five
thousand dollars in debt so much that
were more both lawyers well I'm an
attorney we're waiting on his bar exam
results to come out if you just look at
this summer we're getting married in
three weeks and we've budgeted $2,500
for a honeymoon he's passionate our
wedding the whole thing including
honeymoon is going to be $9,500 my mom
is a big proponent of you is kind of
thinking that feel bad about taking a
honeymoon and I'm sort of wondering like
sorry that got done to you I'm sorry
that got done to you and my name
I assume the your household income when
you return and he passes the bar within
a year will be 200 plus hopefully right
now we're sitting at about 75 thousand
hopefully he's gonna get an associates
job that's gonna make about 90 thousand
and then I'm hoping to get bumped up and
job in the spring yeah so you make you
have a three hundred seventy five
thousand dollars worth of debt you've
had a $9,000 honeymoon or a $9,000
wedding you want to do a $2,500
honeymoon and $9,500 is wedding and
honeymoon all the whole thing and that
includes two thousand five hundred for
the honeymoon yeah okay I'm making sure
I got the numbers right let me tell you
what I would do if I were in your shoes
I would go on the honeymoon
okay your mom is wrong okay that's okay
but let's talk this through for a second
okay if you want to spend twenty five
thousand on the honeymoon yeah I'd
probably smack you around a little you
know I'm saying because that would that
would actually make a dent on the three
375,000 but what makes a dent on the
375,000 is not your honeymoon it's your
income when you get back yeah absolutely
and that's that's my reasoning too and
out of numbers out of your numbers this
honeymoon is like buying a biscuit right
but if you you know if you if it was
like buying a car we'd not buy the car I
would agree with your mom at that point
but I think your mom's got her Dave
Ramsey tired
I got her Dave Ramsey knob up about one
notch to I crap that I didn't do but you
know so how do you know you know but no
I mean she listened she just wants
what's good for you and she wants you to
get out of that she's she's scared to
death that you have this much death
that's all it is so we'll cut it will
cut her a little slack but if I woke up
in your shoes I would go on the
honeymoon
okay cool well you'll be happy to know
that Dave Ramsey is certainly not a
customer than me in my new household my
fiance and I have been doing SP you for
the past seven weeks or almost done well
especially now that you get to go on a
honeymoon so what is the marriage again
so we're getting married October 2nd
it's on a Tuesday good for you well
congratulations thank you very much
we're very excited you should be your
future so bright
Thanks we think so too we're really
going to attract this that and hopefully
be out of it within five years of all
you are you absolutely are you're gonna
make it I'm proud of you go get it not
proud of the debt but I'm proud of you
the way you're thinking the way the fact
that you do think and can think you're
excited you've got a future you got a
game plan you're cleaning up the mess
you're gonna be great you guys are just
gonna be great that debt is gonna go
away so fast because you're so
concentrating so well done well done and
we won't pick on mom too bad she means
well but I think she's just got a dialed
up a little too hot we'll turn the heat
down one notch they're actually put a
honeymoon back in the budget at that
level anyway you know I've worked really
really hard to
to help a whole lot of people and in the
process I've gotten well known and
that's a blessing but my name is used as
a verb sometimes that is Dave Ramsey
there's a day I'm pretty hardcore but
I'm not nearly as hardcore as my
reputation of me is this is the Dave
Ramsey chef
[Music]